weil ich für dich niemals gleich sein
werde schreibt die schwarze
demonstranten der weißen entgegen
im lincoln park in washington dc lässt
sich an diesem abend eine diskussion
beobachten die exemplarisch für das
gespaltene amerika in diesen tagen steht
ein teil des streits dreht sich um diese
abraham lincoln statue die einige hier
nicht mehr haben wollen
andere schon ich zahle steuern nie
gehört die statue
sie gehört uns doch alle im großen geht
es aber um viel mehr um die geschichte
der sklaverei um rassismus um weiße
privilegien um die zukunft von schwarzen
menschen in diesem land zu sehen ist der
ehemalige präsident lincoln zu seinen
füßen ein schwarzer sklaven die szene
soll die abschaffung der sklaverei im
neunzehnten jahrhundert darstellen
das sehen viele hier ganz anders wenn
das eine statue von dir wer auf sein
team vor einem anderen mann als würdest
du ihm die aus bronze ausgestellt vor
den augen der welt in der hauptstadt
lass mich ausreden wird 200 jahre
würdest du dich geschmeichelt bestärkt
oder ermutigt fühlen dass das in der
stadt und den geschichtsbüchern steht
wie würde sich das anfühlen wenn du das
wär ich glaube dass diese statue für
einen befreiten sklaven steht der
aufstehen wird
gebt ihr keine plattform rufen sie seit
dem tod von george floyd fordern viele
menschen im ganzen land schwarze und
weiße denkmäler die die geschichte der
sklaverei beschönigen müssen weg einige
halten dagegen halten an dieser
geschichtsschreibung fest
ich glaube dass viele menschen die
geschichte nicht wirklich kennen das
wird in schulen in den usa nicht
unterrichtet der grausame tat der
geschichte unseres landes die bücher
sind weiß gefärbt sagt becker die mit
ihrer familie fast täglich in diesem
park ist sie und ihr mann hip sind sich
einig wer diese geschichtsschreibung
unterstützt er kennt auch dass rassismus
problem im land nicht an
[Musik]
es verläuft nicht die lebenswirklichkeit
und menschlichkeit von personen solltest
du auch angefangen
jemand hat entschieden dass wir weniger
wert weniger menschen
[Musik]
währenddessen droht präsident tram wer
die statuen beschädigt wird hart
bestraft
um viele wird nun ein zaun errichtet der
streit an diesem abend wird sich nicht
lösen im gegenteil die fronten verhärten
sich immer mehr weil ich schwarz bin
zählt meine meinung hier mehr
nein tut sie nicht weil du weißt bis
glaubst du zählst mehr
am ende gingen sie auseinander ohne
einander zu verstehen